somehow we make the smooth segway to
michael silver the nfl network reporter
and uh i don't know if he's ever been
confronted in a way like that where you
thought maybe you were going to uh
be harmed michael have you had one of
those moments in your career
well obviously dan uh first of all i was
told that there would be a guest host so
i couldn't get trey wingo but uh i'm
sorry michael i'm sorry if you were
deceived
um you know early on i started out
covering the
49ers uh in 1989 and early on i was on a
uh
trip to atlanta it's in the marriott
marquis with those glass elevators and
on a sunday morning only charles haley
and i were in the elevator
and he stared at me with
a and i want to throw you out of this
elevator face
and you know we had our back and forth
and he was a little erratic but i
i was kind of surprised so i tried
humor and i said what's that your game
face and he goes
it's the only face you're going to see
for the rest of the year and i was like
you know what
4 16. getting off a little early bye
you got off on a floor that wasn't even
your floor not my floor
no not at all all right you got my
attention yesterday the seahawks are
staying quiet in the wake of russell
wilson's recent comments on this show
but um are they are they taking calls
or are they shopping him uh well
i i think you definitely got their
attention um you
collectively your show and and russell
and some subsequent appearances
uh you know it was if i'm not wrong it
was time to the man of the year award
which is a great honor and
i think they were a little taken aback
and and caught off
guard and not thrilled uh but you know
there's a long
road between not thrilled and we're
trading our
franchise quarterback but um you have
two things going on
one uh you know your show is popular and
the rest of the league
the rest of the league took notice and
teams started calling
like hey um what's going on with russell
and you have john schneider the general
manager who i believe is the best in the
game
but one thing that he has always been
true to is
he's not one of these gm's who just says
nope not talking
for example nick casario the new gm of
the texans
currently has been telling teams calling
about
sean watson who has asked to be traded
we are not trading him now
i believe they will trade him ultimately
but
they are not even entertaining those
conversations but
john schneider has always been a guy who
just says well
i mean i think we're not training
russell wilson but since you called
what you know what are you thinking so
um
i said yesterday about a third of the
league has called and
there's a sense out there and this is
from team side not from the seahawks
side
that three first-round picks is about
where it would start
um you know do i think pete carroll
wants to start over with a new
quarterback and
reboot at this stage of his career no
uh but you know they they definitely are
aware that
they have a quarterback who was at the
very least acting out
do you know the 10 teams i know some of
them
i just you know i i haven't really
reported who
has called specifically on this one but
can we do that now
we know that no but we know the teams
that are aggressively seeking
quarterbacks right
um there are a lot of them and there are
some some of those teams have
quarterbacks that's why
this is so hard for not only me but
actual
gm's and decision makers to wrap their
arms around because
you know it's the brady effect it's post
brady fever but
you know last year seemed wild now we
have a situation where
not only do you have all these enticing
people coming out in the draft not only
do you have
people who are potentially free and then
you look at now ben roethlisberger's
potentially in play
but then you have the domino effect guys
for example
if the raiders say you know russell
wilson for three ones we could maybe get
a one for derek carr
and that's two more ones uh let's go
well then derek carr is now in play is
jimmy garoppolo in play
where kirk cousins or matt ryan being
played uh so that's why
i i think timing is is really really key
and we've seen
the staff for golf dominoes fall we saw
the wet's domino fall
now you know there's darnold there's
roethlisberger there's
potentially russell i don't think it'll
come to that but
it's all being talked about do you think
there's been an offer
like a true offer for russell wilson um
that's a great question i think the way
that john schneider communicates
uh he probably has a sense of a very
basic framework of what teams would
uh throw out there but no i don't think
what you and i would consider a
reportable offer as journalists
my guess is no but i honestly don't know
because i will say this
about the seahawks unlike the texans who
are the only ones talking in that
situation and the player
is not publicly talking to sean watson i
i hate that i called him
the player because that was sarcasm
because that's what nick casario
referred to him as it's an old
belichick parcells thing so that was a
joke but
in the seahawks case wilson is the one
who has talked
and they are intentionally being very
very
publicly quiet i'm always fascinated
with the niners because it feels like
the niners are in on other quarterbacks
but then they try to tell you
hey but jimmy garoppolo is our
quarterback jimmy garoppolo is your
quarterback now
he's not your quarterback for the future
in my opinion
so why the charade here with what's
going on are the niners
in the market for an upgrade over jimmy
garoppolo
okay well first of all there's this
whole new honesty thing
and i had this conversation with sean
mcveigh even before jared goff was
traded because
he was committed to not lying in his
mind and i was like yeah but
you know i mean it started with uh i
love all these people it started with
steve keim
when they asked him about josh rosen at
the combine when they had the first
overall pick and he goes
yeah yeah josh is our quarterback for
sure right now
and i was like yeah don't try that with
your spouses at home
you know honey you're definitely my my
soul mate right now
uh that won't work so then uh you know
then obviously
mcveigh did it and you know les sneed
then kind of went out and tried to do
bad stand-up comedy and i thought it
disrespected
a player that didn't deserve it in goff
and
finally we had kevin colbert who doesn't
speak public
publicly much i do it with ben and kind
of like
whoa whoa so um you know i think
what the 49ers kind of like the raiders
with derek carr have been pretty
consistent on message
which is we love this guy he's our guy
we're always looking at every position
and possibly upgrading
i think the most likely scenario with
the niners would be
jimmy's back with a young quarterback uh
you know whether he's drafted or a young
guy they trade for
to compliment him but it is possible
that he won't
be and so you know you look at a kirk
cousins i know how i see kirk customs i
know how fans
by and large secret cousins and i know
how a lot of other
talent evaluators and coaches see kirk
cousins but i also know that
kyle shanahan sean mcvay matt lafleur
mike mcdaniel those great coaches who
had him in washington
see him much differently and you know
they believe
in their system that he's a really
really really good player
so i always kind of wonder is that
something that
the 49ers would be able to swing if
minnesota would
you know would part with them um you
know kyle had matt ryan
darnold's out there um you know and
deshawn watson is kind of sitting out
there
you know obviously a lot of teams will
be very very interested but there's
price
and there's timing and all that he's
michael silver you can follow him nfl
network reporter
on twitter at michael silver are the
steelers telling ben but ben's not
picking up on the hint
that they're ready to move on but let's
do this in a gracious manner and we'll
let you go out in style
i'm really torn on this one because uh
you know i'm told that kevin colbert
after he spoke publicly reached out to
ben's camp and was like whoa whoa
whoa that's not not what it seemed so i
want to believe that logically
um you know they had a talk with ben
right after the season he was like look
i want to come back they were like okay
but we
might be doing some extreme home
makeover stuff so let's talk in a few
weeks and be sure
and ben's like no no i'm sure well
pouncey has since retired a very
important guy
i think we all look at the steelers free
agents and
cap situation and we go they're going to
have to make some hard choices so i
think what's going to happen next is
they're going to have a conversation
pretty soon this week maybe next week
with ben
uh you know guys who've men who've done
a lot of
business together for a long time are
rooney kevin colbert mike tomlin
once he recovers uh from covet and uh
and ben and they'll say look this is
what our team's gonna look like
you sure you you're into this now it's
possible you're right that they're gonna
say
dude we just to reboot thank you for
your service
you know or something to that effect if
that's the case
i talked to one head coach of a you know
pretty uh stacked
team who uh told me
yeah i'm in that market not like i'm
definitely signing ben roethlisberger
but
i want to have that uh conversation for
sure so
then the question would become does ben
want to keep playing elsewhere and
you know we've seen mourinho say no to
that question
aikman said no uh montana said yes
farv said yes uh you know brady said yes
so it's
it's one of those uh interesting uh
scenarios
if you had to bet a week's pay russell
wilson
under center when the seahawks open up
the season
well now you know you know that i do
okay right i was at si went to yahoo
and i advantageous time that nfl network
swooped
me up so i'm not a gambler but now i'm
i'm really i gotta really like be right
about this um
i would bet that russell wilson is a
seahawk but um
i don't want to i don't want anyone to
just
take that out of context i what happened
on your show
was a very legitimately significant
event in the nfl world it has changed
the course of some teams
thinking including the seahawks and if
he doesn't get traded i don't want
people to
circle back and go oh damn patrick hype
that thing uh you know like this is
this is real well i didn't hype it up
all i did
yeah i mean i that was your guest host
that was trey wingo yeah i think
no but i i had net i had every network
called during the show
while i was doing the interview saying
we want the russell wilson
interview and i don't know about the
first round picks and you said a third
of the league is calling but i
i don't have any information on that i
just know that
i was told by a source that this isn't
sustainable under the
current condition but that was that was
a follow-up to what russell was
saying which as we know it's
uncharacteristic for russ to say what he
said because he famously
tries his best to not say anything well
and the and the caveat
is that you know russell wilson uh could
go to them
today and say i don't want to be here
and i think in that scenario
uh as with the texans and deshawn watson
you have a
much more interesting stare down uh you
know you've had
we have plenty of nfl executives and
coaches who
in that situation would say i'm not
letting a player force his way out
i will put my foot down mike brown tried
it with carson palmer
and even mike brown who you would think
on paper would do
would make carson palmer wait for 10
years he only made it to october
before you know the raiders convinced
him to
part on the other hand remember kobe
bryant uh the late great kobe bryant
told the lakers
i want to get out of here i want to be
on the clippers and they were like
i can't really hear you um
and that worked out for the lakers and
kobe so i don't know
michael great to talk to you you too
thank you buddy that's uh michael silver
nfl network
reporter